au menu de cet atelier de cuisine
japonaise sushis et california maquis
pour les quinze inscrits entouré du chef
chauray rhein jian pour la deuxième
année consécutive l'atelier proposé à
guyancourt fait découvrir en toute
simplicité les bases de la cuisine
japonaise
après un cours sur la cuisson du riz et
la découpe des sushis les participants
ont créé leurs propres recettes
ainsi sous mon crevettes avocats ou
encore feuilles de menthe et cacahuètes
tout peut être roulé dans le riz la chef
apporte tous les ingrédients et les
ustensiles nécessaires à la réalisation
d'un sushi et d'un acquis j'insiste
beaucoup sur la qualité des produits
d'abord c'est à dire que le poisson doit
être vraiment très frais on n'achète pas
dans un étal de supermarché on va au
marché on en parle à son poissonnier on
le fait préparer donc c'est la fraîcheur
déjà qui va faire la qualité du sushi et
aussi le fait de parts sont intoxiqués
vous pouvez si vous voulez mélange est
probablement un souci chez nombreux
vêtements ça va très bien ensemble avec
la cacahuète jamais beaucoup cuisiner et
on m'en avait parlé l'année dernière
notre l'année dernière
et cette année n'a réussi à s'inscrire
voilà on est avec des communes c'est
plaisant à manger donc je me suis dit je
pouvais peut-être le faire moi-même
comment ça se passe a finalement c'est
pas si difficile que ça et je pense que
non le rsa a été sans difficulté aucune
un second atelier de cuisine japonaise
pourrait se programmer au cours de cette
année